there should be
a preparation given to the biden team
should he be the winner not if he's
going to be the winner but should he be
the winner make sure he's prepared on
day one
and that's something that the transition
process
should allow to have happen
all right that was andy carter president
bush juniors as a former chief of staff
co-wrote an article
in the wall street journal with john
podesta who served in that role for bill
clinton saying that enough is enough we
should not be
making way for a smooth transition uh to
joe biden if for no other reason then
uh that he should be prepared uh january
20th and have plenty of time
for a transition that is not being
afforded him now including
intelligence briefings and the like that
are very important to have
uh no doubt my next guest agrees jeff
lake the former arizona
senator who had supported joe biden in
this effort joins us right now senator
thank you for doing so very good to have
you on a saturday
good to be here um senator as you know i
mean
republicans and democrats are
increasingly calling at the very least
no matter what the president
thinks of of this race and whether it
was fair to him that joe biden
is owed these intelligence briefings
that it's important that
a delay in getting to them back in 2000
uh with the bush score recount might
have left us vulnerable to what happened
eight months later of course on 9 11. do
you agree
with that i agree that it's important uh
i can't speculate as to whether that
would have made a difference with 9 11
but it's just the right thing to do
i think responsible administrations uh
will make sure
that uh responsible outgoing
administrations make sure that that
happens so
i hope it does and i i expect that it
will in the coming weeks um it's been
you know a long haul to get here but i i
assume that by next week
most will agree um i know you had a very
pesticide with the president um and then
he would return the salvo with you
uh i am wondering now though how you
think
um he will comport himself if his
options run out
do you think that he will graciously
concede the election to joe biden and
will attend
the inauguration of joe biden i don't
know all indications are that uh that
he's going to ride this out
uh so i'm not sure what what he's going
to do
but i think the rest of us need to
realize that this
this now says more about us and how we
handle it than it does about the
president
uh but uh i i can't i i
i would think that by the time the
inauguration rolls around
uh that he'll he'll be there but uh
who knows who knows i understand
senator um indications he's he's sort of
paving away for a 2024
run um that would that would be
certainly historically unusual a grover
cleveland did that and there are only
two-term non-concurrent term president i
remember covering that election but
no i'm joking there but what do you
think of that and the likelihood of that
you know i i don't think the president
is going to have an outsized influence
he will have an influence going forward
but once you lose the trappings of
office and the levers of power
and then in particular you know trumpism
kind of relies on a certain amount of
swagger
that that you lose when you lose an
election
and so i i just can't see i mean some
people are thinking that he's
going to be the the 900 pound gorilla
that's going to determine
every senate race and every house race
in the next four years
i just don't see that i do think he will
exert some
influence the fact that there are
rallies going around the country right
now i think indicate that
but uh but that's hard to maintain when
you lose like i said the trappings of
office and the levers of power
indeed in grover cleveland's case he had
won the popular vote um
so he could make a stake on that you
know he was robbed or whatever um
in in battling for a third bid for
office but leaving that
aside uh you you mentioned the the force
of nature he is i'm not i'm not quoting
you exactly here
in the party itself and and how he could
decide
on its its next nominee that trumpism
isn't dead and then that's still and the
supporters he has including
all these showing up senator in
washington today to express their
support and the legal fight to continue
what do you make of that and the
influence that these these supporters
will have on the party well he will have
influence no doubt
and like i said the fact that these
rallies are going wrong a lot of people
attending them he had a lot of support
he got 72 million votes
um but having said that you know trump
isn't
it's more of an attitude really um it uh
relies a lot on on grievance politics
and depending on where both of the
parties
that are governing that are in the
senate and in the house in the white
house
depending on how republicans and
democrats uh comport themselves and move
forward
if they do you know reach toward the
center then i think people will
kind of tire of the old uh the old
politics that we experience right now
and they'll
go more back to their regular lives and
uh so
i i think that to see politics as kind
of entertainment as we've seen it over
the past uh little while
particularly during covent when the
sports were down for a while and
everything else it was politics that we
all turned to
but i think that will fade i hope it
does as a conservative i want
you know politics to be steady and civil
and boring
and that would be nice senator your name
has been mentioned oftentimes in a
potential biden
cabinet would you be interested in a
role
i i don't expect that to happen uh
obviously i i love
this country i will serve in whatever
way i can but uh i don't expect that to
happen
you know there have been precedents
chuck hagel for one uh defense secretary
with president obama so it's not
unthinkable right
no no no it happens more often than not
frankly but uh right but whether i would
be chosen that's that's
that's what i my question okay
senator flake thank you for taking the
time we appreciate it sir glad to be on
thank you